AS WE REPORTED LAST WEEK, THE
EASTERN UKRAINIAN TOWN OF --
HAS BECOME A PRIME TARGET FOR
RUSSIAN TROOPS.
FEROCIOUS FIGHTING IS UNDERWAY
THERE AND KYIV'S FORCES ARE
GETTING A BOOST FROM AN
UNLIKELY SOURCE.
RUSSIANS THEMSELVES VOLUNTEERS
WHO HAVE COME IN TO FIGHT ON
THEIR OWN AGAINST THEIR
COUNTRYMEN FOR UKRAINIANS.
CORRESPONDENT, SAM KILEY HAS
OUR REPORT.
>> --
HE'S TAKING A BREAK AND
MONASTERY FROM FIGHTING
RUSSIANS IN NEARBY --
IT'S A RELIEF FROM SCENES LIKE
THIS.
HIS UKRAINIAN FIELD HOSPITAL.
HE'S BEEN DEFENDING THIS
UKRAINIAN TOWN FROM RUSSIA'S
MOST INTENSE ASSAULT ALONG AN
800 MILE FRONT.
ARTILLERY JEWELS AND TRENCH
WARFARE HAVE ALMOST DESTROYED
--
AS RUSSIA THROWS ITS ARMY AT A
BID FOR VICTORY.
AFTER MONTHS OF DEFEAT TO THE
NORTH AND SOUTH.
DEFENDING --
AGAINST RUSSIAN MOTHERLAND IT'S
A RELIGIOUS IMPERATIVE FOR
CESAR.
THE FIGHTING IS VERY BRUTAL NOW,
HE SAYS.
THERE ARE VERY FEW PRISONERS.
>> WHEN YOU SEE THOSE RUSSIANS
IN NEW YORK ON SITES, WHAT DO
YOU THINK?
WHAT DO YOU FEEL?
>> I BELIEVE THAT THESE PEOPLE
HAVE BROKEN THE LAW OF MAINE
AND THE LAW OF GOD.
I HAVE NO PITY FOR THEM.
I TAKE THEM PRISONER IF I CAN.
BUT MOST OFTEN, I JUST HAVE TO
KILL THEM.
>> IF YOU KILLED A LAWYER
COUNTRYMEN?
>> A DOZEN AND A HALF.
>> THIS IS THE REMAINS OF
RUSSIAN ORTHODOX MONASTERY.
FOR VLADIMIR PUTIN, THE
ORTHODOX CHURCH IS ABSOLUTELY
CENTRAL TO HIS VISION OF THE
RUSSIAN WORLD.
FOR SOME RUSSIANS, THAT'S A
WORLD THEY DON'T WANT TO LIVE
IN.
INDEED, THEY DON'T WANT IT TO
SURVIVE.
>> UKRAINE'S ORTHODOX CHURCH
BROKE WITH MOSCOW THREE YEARS
AGO THIS IS ALL THAT'S LEFT OF
A RE-BRANDED UKRAINIAN ORTHODOX
ST. GEORGES MONASTERY.
AFTER NINE MONTHS OF WAR, PUTIN
SAYS THAT HIS DEFENSE
TRADITIONAL VALUES.
THIS IS THE RESULT OF HIS
DEFENDANT.
>> HE HAS BEEN FIGHTING HERE
FOR WEEKS.
AGAINST MERCENARIES FROM
RUSSIA'S EFFECT YOUR COMPANY.
MANY OF THEM CONVICTED
CRIMINALS.
>> IT'S OBVIOUS, HE SAYS.
WHEN PRIVATE COMPANIES HIRE
CRIMINALS AND CONVICTS,
IMAGINE.
A MAN KILLS ONCE IN THE PUT HIM
IN JAIL.
BECAUSE THE SECOND TIME AND HE
BECOMES A REPEAT OFFENDER UNDER
THE LAW.
THEN HE GETS LET OUT OF JAIL
AND GIVEN A GUN.
THAT'S NOT A PERSON, THAT'S A
BEAST.
>> AFTER A FORMER WAGNER
DISORDER, WAS MURDERED IN A
VIDEO THAT WAS PRAISED BY
WAGNER'S BOSS --
VINNY IS IN NO DOUBT HOW HE
WOULD BE TREATED IF CAPTURED.
ANNE >> IT'LL BE THE END, 100%.
BUT IT'LL JUST BE MORE PAINFUL.
DIRECTIONALLY JIM DOES CLAIM TO
BE IN THE HUNDREDS.
AND IT SAYS MANY MORE BACK HOME
ARE TRYING TO JOIN UKRAINE'S
ARMY.
ALONGSIDE THEIR UKRAINIAN
ALLIES, THE RUSSIAN LEGION IS
FOCUS ON THE BATTLE FOR --
THE AIM OF THE WAR AFTER IS
MORE AMBITIOUS.
HE SAYS I'M DOING MY MILITARY
AND CHRISTIAN DUTY.
I DEFEND THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE
AND WHEN UKRAINE IS FREE, I
WILL CARRY MY SWORD TO RUSSIA
TO FREE IT FROM TYRANNY.
NEW WARNINGS TO TAKE COVER IN
REPORTS OF MORE CASUALTIES AND
DAMAGE A NEW CRANE AS THE
COUNTRY FACES A NEW ROUND OF
MISSILE ATTACKS.
TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT IT
SOUNDED LIKE IN KYIV A SHORT
TIME AGO.
THE SOUND OF AIR RAID SIRENS
BLARING ACROSS THE CAPITAL.
HIS AIR DEFENSE FORCES
INTERCEPTED AND DESTROYED MOST
OF THOSE RUSSIAN MISSILES.
THE LATEST ATTACK APPEARS TO BE
TARGETING BOTH INFRASTRUCTURE
AND RESIDENTIAL AREAS.
THIS IS THE AFTERMATH THAT THE
STRIKES IN THE ZAPORIZHZHIA
REGION.
AT LEAST TWO PEOPLE WERE
REPORTEDLY KILLED THERE.
THE CITY IS BOTH REPORT NO
ELECTRICITY AND NO RUNNING
WATER.
LIKE THOUSANDS OF OTHER PEOPLE
IN AND AROUND THE CAPITAL, WILL
RIPLEY SPENT HOURS IN AN
UNDERGROUND SHELTER AS THOSE
MISSILES FLEW TOWARD THE
CAPITAL.
YOU CAN SEE SOME OF THEM IN THE
METRO STATION.
WE WILL NOW THANKFULLY BE
JOINED BY WILL, BACK ABOVE
GROUND.
TAKE US BACK TO WHAT IT WAS
LIKE WHEN YOU ARE HEARING THOSE
AIR SIRENS OVERHEAD, THAT
BARRAGE OF MISSILES STRIKING
RIGHT ACROSS UKRAINE.
>> YEAH.
IT IS CERTAINLY AN OMINOUS
SOUND WHEN YOU HEAR AIR RAID
SIRENS.
WE HAD JUST FINISHED A LIVE
REPORT FROM THIS LOCATION.
YOU HEARD THE SIRENS CLEARLY.
I GRABBED MY IPHONE AND SHOT
THE VIDEO THAT YOU JUST PLAYED.
WE HAD TO PACK UP AND MOVE
DOWNSTAIRS TO THE UNDERGROUND
SHELTER THAT THEY HAVE.
PEOPLE WHO MIGHT HAVE BEEN AT
WORK OR PEOPLE STAYING IN
VARIOUS HOTELS PROBABLY WENT
DOWN TO THE SHELTERS IN THOSE
RESPECTIVE BUILDINGS.
THERE WERE A LOT OF PEOPLE,
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE, WHO HAD TO
BASICALLY GO UNDERGROUND IN THE
SUBWAY STATION.
IT WAS EITHER STANDING ROOM
ONLY OR A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE
SITTING ON THE STAIRS OR
SITTING ON THE FLOOR.
THAT THAT'S ALL YOU CAN DO.
YOU HAVE LIMITED WATER,
BATHROOMS, FOOD.
THIS IS SEVERAL HOURS THAT
PEOPLE WERE DOWN THERE.
CLEARLY, NOT A COMFORTABLE
SITUATION.
A LOT OF PEOPLE, YOURS TRULY
INCLUDED, GRATEFUL TO COME BACK
UP AND BREATHE SOME FRESH AIR.
EVEN THOUGH THE MAJORITY OF
THESE MISSILES WERE REPORTEDLY
INTERCEPTED, BUT UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS SAY THAT THEY NEEDED
A DECISION FROM THE UNITED
STATES ON MISSILE DEFENSE
SYSTEMS.
THEY'VE BEEN CALLING FOR THEM
FOR MONTHS, AND NOT JUST
PATRIOTS ESTIMATES, BUT OTHER
ADVANCED SYSTEMS.
THE POWER GRID HAS ONCE AGAIN
BEEN AFFECTED HERE IN KYIV.
THERE ARE NOW SCORES OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE WITHOUT ELECTRICITY
BECAUSE OF THE POWER SYSTEM IS
UNSTABLE.
THE SAME IS TRUE IN THE EAST
AND ALASKA AND DOWN SOUTH AND
DNEPROPETROVSK.
PEOPLE WHO ARE LIVING THROUGH
THIS IS A IT'S UNPLEASANT BUT
IT COULD BE MUCH WORSE.